[Music]
hello
welcome everyone to our inaugural
episode
of the technically brilliant show
presented by
the din black film festival institute
and black public media
my name is ebony johnson or i serve as
the director
of dbffi outreach and education
and we're just happy to have you here
with us during this lunch
session um and engage with us as we
connect with black artists filmmakers
who are using virtual reality augmented
reality
and other techniques to tell stories
um guiding armed conversation today is
black public media
media's director of emerging media
lisa osborne so i'm going to bring up
the wonderful lisa
hi lisa hi ebony how are you
i'm good how are you i'm awesome um
i'm really happy to be here this is like
uh
this collaboration uh with denton has
been super cool and i'm really excited
to see where we
go over the next two months with all the
guests we have planned
um we so rarely uh get to see
black creative technologists talk about
you know their work in granular detail
and so i'm really looking forward to
learning more about each person's
process over the course of the eight
episodes
as well as looking at some of their
recent work or the work that they have
in development
um you know i've been an interactive
producer for 25 years
so i really love process conversations
um i like finding out what tools people
are using whether it's hardware or
software
and also how they actually learned how
to use the tool which i think is key
yeah especially with these emerging um
platforms and
and technologies that are coming on
board um
i know that virtual reality and
augmented reality for example
can seem very nebulous to people
um even people who work in creative
professions are like i don't understand
i don't get it um and so i i think our
mutual hope like between denton and
black pulit media
is that you know these interviews uh
make the technologies far
less intimidating and far more
accessible
to black creatives and to black
educators
our first guest today is carla
lindale bishop she's a film professor
and this
this fall she's going to start teaching
film at the sydney poitiers
new american film school at arizona
state university
she's joining us today from norman
oklahoma
carla hi i'm so excited to be on this
show and to talk more about my work so
um thank you for having me
so happy you could join us um carla you
are the first recipient of the
um you are the first recipient of the
mit and blackboard media fellowship
and you've been using the fellowship to
research and develop your american
history project called mapping blackness
so uh really looking forward to
diving into that uh more in this in
today's episode
so ebony i am going to
yes give the stage to you both carlos
lovely to see you
um yes have fun
thank you she's going to be like the
ninja helping us
um so i guess the the obvious question
is
what is mapping blackness about yes um
so mapping blackness is an
interactive digital archive that
documents and preserves the history of
small black towns throughout the united
states so we focus on
local heroes um communal spaces and just
the stories of these black communities
and using
various technologies such as augmented
reality 360 vr
and traditional documentary storytelling
to preserve these and put these on an
interactive map
got it so how long have you been
developing this project
well this has started this has been a a
couple of years it originated as a
traditional um future lens documentary
that i started
in ohio and a community called twinsburg
heights where i did a documentary
working with young people
and they told the history of this
predominantly black community
and we had it in a future length
documentary they went to festivals and
had a really great reception
but i realized there were limitations to
that because um
just there were more stories that we
weren't able to capture in that
traditional documentary form
got it okay learning other ways to do
interactive technology and also so that
we could build on these stories and that
led me down a path
to do more interactive documentaries of
these communities
got it okay so basically you
started to explore emerging tech because
traditional film
was too limiting like you couldn't scale
it and
accommodate multiple as many stories as
you'd like to from that particular town
absolutely i feel like
traditional route we will have like an
80-hour documentary
using like um different forms of
technology allows to have like
bite-sized stories that are one to two
minutes long on different topics and
people
okay and it's something that you can
build upon over time so over
years so i noticed with that project
when we're done it was just like there's
so many more stories to get
and i also noticed that even with
traditional documentary there weren't a
lot of young people that
go to film festivals to see these films
that is correct
on the way to get young people involved
in this history and creating it and
watching it so i thought what better way
than using mobile technology
um the time when i had the ideas when
pokemon go was really huge
and i saw how my kids were using that
app to just
interact with different spaces in a
physical way so
i have a moment thing about some of
these black towns that are no longer
in existence how can we still tell their
stories using
ar and vr so if you're walking down the
street you can see
the church that used to be there the
homes that used to be there right
using mobile technology when you tried
pokemon go
you know all those years ago when it had
that explosion that one year
of of usage had had you ever used an
ar tool before like had you already were
you already were your kids already
exposing you to snapchat filters and
stuff like that or
filters um i went to a few like
workshops and conferences where i saw a
few other artists that were using it in
creative ways
but it was still really i was still
relatively new to it and uh okay
i was trying to find have you seen it
used it like at the conferences but had
i i assume like in real life you're
seeing it used for pop culture ways but
then at the conference you're seeing it
used for academic ways have you ever
seen any
academic uses of ar or augmented reality
out in the wild like
outside of the conference at that time i
wasn't really seeing it i wasn't
and in terms of ar and vr i wasn't
seeing it document black history in this
way i hadn't seen that right
over that overlap and now it's i'm
seeing it more and more but
just okay years ago flag was still
relatively a new way of telling these
types of stories
got it should we watch the video the
pitch video that you developed a month
ago for the bpm plus showcase let's do
it
um let's see sure
oh no cancel
is it visible
carla now it's yeah i see it now
okay gotcha it just had a delay all
right i'm
hopefully the audio is shared as well so
this will be an adventure
i'm gonna press play
when were you born and what
why did you move well
i was born in uh cortland alabama
uh i came here in 49
instead of 49.
mapping blackness is a digital archive
that celebrates the heroes
communal spaces and hearts of
historically black communities
the project was created by carla lindell
bishop
who is a filmmaker and educator her goal
is to bring communities together and
promote social change
this project utilizes an
intergenerational approach to
storytelling
mapping blackness trains young people to
interview elders in black neighborhoods
carlos process teaches them to research
and shoot
documentary interviews and to create
interactive media
most of the content in mapping blackness
is produced by students
not professional filmmakers or
technologists the archive uses
geotagging augmented reality 360 virtual
reality
3d images and traditional documentary
storytelling
mapping blackness teaches young people
to create location-based stories
that add images and videos to digital
maps this empowers
young people to co-create authentic
history
with the members of each black community
in this respect
carl abused mapping blackness as a form
of activism
this man my husband
called jane young
he was and still is the love of my life
my dad was jw a fat he's one of the
first black
businessman
[Music]
this was initially was a farmland
that he didn't have years ago and uh
he had some convictions concerning
minorities
they wouldn't let them into that area so
this farmer donated all this anchorage
up here called the heights
and he donated it to the people
and helped build the church that was
baptist church
it was based
[Music]
[Music]
this digital archive will also invite
audiences
to virtually visit spaces that are no
longer in existence
it will include 3d and vr renderings of
such spaces
audiences will be able to access these
images and spaces
via the website and your mobile offer
community screenings are an integral
part of the distribution
and engagement strategy for this project
[Applause]
this project is influenced and inspired
by the many black elders who built their
neighborhoods
from almost nothing some of these
communities are still thriving
while others are almost obsolete carla
believes that it is vitally important to
preserve their stories
and their legacies the history of small
town black america
is complicated and frankly still untold
mapping blackness is in a race to
capture the history of these towns
currently the archive is in its
prototyping phase
carla is creating sample community
profiles
using video vr and photo assets from two
towns in ohio and texas
when the demos are finished they will
serve as examples for future
contributors
to the mapping blackness archive carla
is seeking funding to complete a design
and definition phase
for the web and mobile interface this
phase will require
the support of a ux designer and a
developer
additional crew members will include a
motion graphics designer
media manager 3d designer and curriculum
writer
the total to design develop and launch
the mapping blackness archive
is 350 000 so far carla has raised forty
thousand dollars from university
black public media mit and in-kind
donations
hi my name is carla lindell bishop
creator of matthew blackness
in mapping black stories i'm also
mapping myself
my family's histories stories and
language
mapping blackness is a digital archive
that can house
these amazing stories that are often
missing from history books and
newspapers
it's important that we document preserve
and celebrate these stories
in a way that is shareable so that
everyone can access
so that there aren't issues of
accessibility in black communities
i am seeking funding on partnerships to
help make mapping blackness a reality
help me reach my goal of documenting at
least 50 historically black communities
across the united states
fantastic never get tired of seeing that
video
um so um
[Music]
where did you let's back up a bit give
people a little bit more context about
your professional training
so where did you go to film school
so undergrad i went to university of
chicago
and i had more of a specialty in um
cinema studies i learned about film
history i had a great professor
jacqueline stewart who taught me about
the history of black cinema and really
fell in love with just
studying black films and then i went to
grad school i got my mfa at temple
university where i learned more the
production side
cameras directing got it let's continue
from there
also in philadelphia i worked with some
great nonprofits who are doing
similar type of community work um such
as cry video center where they go out
into communities and help them tell
their stories
so i had a lot of great mentors in
school and um in the cities where
where did you grow up like where were
you because i noticed both schools are
in the midwest where did you so i was
born in cleveland ohio and then i moved
to twinsburg ohio which is just next
door and that was oh so that's why you
were documenting
oh you got you used to live there that's
definitely the inspiration
um for this work and that really
spiraled me into doing a lot more of
this um documenting black communities
because i realized they're
all over this country and their stories
aren't being told
um by the people who lived it and that's
really important to me to make sure that
residents are telling their stories and
their histories for future generations
so can be preserved
yeah so now that you
started um the fellowship that we
created with mit
you were our first recipient of the mit
and black global media fellowship
last september when school started
how have you how have you managed to
move the project forward
during the one year that you've been
part of the mit open documentary lab
community
right so this year has been really great
for just um creating a prototype a lot
of times when i tell people what i'm
trying to do it's hard to explain it
without them physically seeing it so
right part of this
fellowship i've been able to talk to a
lot of different technologists people
who are developers and programmers
to help guide me to get to a point where
i can create that prototype so i can
show
everyone an example of what i'm trying
to do and at the end of
hopefully towards the early fall i'll
have a nice robust prototype
using the communities i've already
documented as a real example to show
future communities how this process
works and how they can contribute to
their own histories on this map
got it were there any technologies that
stand out that you've learned about in
the last year whether
you know from the open dock lab
community or elsewhere
that you are investigating or kind of
blew your mind or anything like that
um photogrammetry volumetric filmmaking
all those are really great ways
especially to preserve some of these
historical buildings and churches and
homes
right i also love just just not old
school which is rather 3d renderings and
i have a little bit of a game design
background i've used unity game design
software
and just recreating some of these
buildings that aren't there and just
having another way to preserve them in a
digital format
um has been exciting i'm also using um
arches
their storymaps application as a way to
integrate the um
and geotag some of these spaces as well
got it
so do you think that your platform when
it's built will have
a way to sort like i can search but i
can say the type of file that i'm
looking for like i only want to see
3d files or i only want to see vr files
or i only want to see
augmented reality files do you think
that your lesson is going to work
so there's a way where definitely the
structure you'll be able to um
search for using metadata so even you
know from the technology aspect you can
search for various assets but also
um just subject-wise so if you're
looking up black is
you can aggregate that and type that in
and you'll see the black churches
all across the united states and what i
love about this project is that there
are so many similar stories i'm learning
so even a story in ohio versus oklahoma
there are similar histories in terms of
how these black communities were formed
so you could even
see those um similarities but then we'll
see the uniqueness in each neighborhood
and how
each neighborhood formed in a slightly
different manner has a slightly
different history
right see the churches and the schools
and different aspects and search those
as well
cool cool um ebony do we have any
audience questions
because if so this would be a perfect
time to take our first question
[Music]
oh wait and if okay so important to
empower
it looks like it's cut off i can't it's
cut off yet to empower the neighborhood
to document their community's history
um aseal borsala just has a comment it's
so important to empower
the neighborhood to document their
communities history we agree
um i think there's something i think you
have mentioned
before about how when you have gone into
each community
and looked at the quote-unquote official
record
in newspaper archives and you know
court records and things like that that
the community
um the way that the community is
described in those documents the public
documents is quite different than
the way that the residents whether
they're children of people who form the
community or
actual elders who grew up in the
community um
the way that they describe their own
community has that been consistent
across in your work and and that just
comes historically you know we weren't
writing newspapers you know back in the
day or there were definitely a lot of
black newspapers that i want to include
in this archive but
mainstream media we didn't always have
the control or the power to tell our own
story so this is a way
to make sure we're getting our stories
out there from our own point of view so
i think that's great
that's what's already out there do you
know is there a
um a central database
that you can search of black papers like
have they been digitized
there's a lot of archives that i've come
across that mostly they're housed
within universities and there's also
journals and academic journals that also
house um a lot of these historically
black newspapers that are becoming
digitized
they haven't been consolidated into one
searchable
black newspaper i don't know
not that i know of all library way to
access so mostly
through library archives is what i'm
finding okay so you have to like access
each one independently um how did you
start when after you were exposed to
pokemon go
and you know filters on things like
snapchat started
seeing it at conferences how did you set
about actually
teaching yourself augmented reality for
example
right i mean definitely a lot of it was
self-taught because that you know a few
even a few years ago it wasn't like
there were
a lot of books about the subject and
even as we imprinted they were almost
outdated instantly so right just doing
research on my own practicing a lot of
experimenting
testing seeing what technology was out
there i used a lot of open source apps
um
a few years ago there's one called hp
reveal and erasmus those are now like
defunct and whatnot and
and that's kind of the the hard thing
about augmented reality is always
changing
there's always a newer app so when
mapping blackness i'm working with
developers to create their you know its
own app that's you know more
controllable and that will be able to
modify as needed um but it was basically
a lot of just researching
and experimenting and figuring out what
worked for my needs versus what didn't
interesting um so we have a question
from the audience from laflin lamb
productions
do you have any particular community
partner that you want to work with
um community partner in terms of like
specific neighborhoods or organizations
let's assume that they mean
what type of community partner would you
normally um partner with to go profile a
community
right a lot of times i'll so far my
research has been
um it's worked two ways i've had some
communities come to me
telling me that they want their
communities documented but also research
there's a lot of ways just to see you
know just census data where is where are
these black communities a lot of them
aren't their own cities they're not
their own municipalities
they're like small neighborhoods within
a larger city and
just about every city has them like due
to red lining and segregation a lot of
times they're behind the railroad tracks
near factories
and they're secluded and um those are
the communities i'm most attracted to
those are the ones where you don't see
them in mainstream media so
just doing research those are relatively
easy for for me to find
and identify right just um having
communities reach out to me and those
who want their stories told i try to
help and be
be a facilitator to help get their
stories told
got it so do you have a short list
running of like your dream
towns that you want okay got it got it
yeah i've been working on that list even
here in oklahoma oklahoma at one point
had the most historically black towns in
the country at one point i had 55
and right now jungle down to 13. so post
slavery you know um you know one
when a lot of these come when a lot of
these residents were migrating
a lot of them made a stop in oklahoma on
their way to kansas so there's a lot of
history
where a lot of black communities
migrated from the south during that
great migration
so that has been somewhat of my running
list to initially start but they're all
over like oh you know hawaii
i get all of this all of these
communities throughout the us
55 yes
yes wow that is mind-blowing i
oklahoma is not some place that i think
i or the average black person
associate with the black diaspora or
blackness in general
and the only thing you hear is black
wall street you hear about tulsa
other communities that thrived and some
that didn't but their stories aren't
told like they're
overshadowed by a lot of these other
communities so it's important to get
their histories and just even to
preserve them so i want this to be like
a living
museum like with images photographs
video
and just preserving these communities
for generations to come
right and then how about virtual reality
where were you first exposed to that
because what i find interesting about
your perspective is that you're
an educator so you know you're teaching
at universities
and um i always wonder when you're
already
when you're a person who's supposed to
pass information off to the next
generation
how do you stay up to speed on the
latest tech
you know what i mean because i know that
what i've seen is that the latest
technologies usually are incubated by
um big research universities as well as
independent artists and filmmakers who
are
you know uh essentially hacking and
trying to break things and making
you know doing working doing skunk works
and
um so there's like this intersection
between the two
and then when you bring in like um
government funding like military funding
that tends to add infusions of cash you
know especially at the big research
universities to
develop certain technologies so i'm
always curious every person i meet who
works in this field
where did you first get exposed to vr
and you know how did you start to teach
yourself about it
um i guess what what's interesting even
though
i love emerging technology i'm still an
old school filmmaker
i'm led by the story so whatever's going
to serve the story so in terms of vr
what really attracts me to it is um
just the fact that some of these
communities aren't there anymore there's
a
community called quakertown in denton
texas that was
black wall street they had their own you
know stores hospital or you know doctors
churches and they were thriving and they
were forcibly removed
from their community to another part of
town so the way i was thinking about
retelling this story is how can i tell a
story for a place that no longer exists
right yard came in its mind so how do
you transport
um the audience to this space where you
can see the grocery store where you can
see
the schools and that's where the
technology really served me so i wasn't
necessarily
chasing the technology i was just
thinking tell these stories for
places that aren't in existence or also
how to preserve them so even using
um a 360 vr camera some of these spaces
i want to
transport people to these churches or to
these homes that were built by their
great
grandfathers so they can see what it's
like to be inside and hear the voices of
the people that were there and hear the
choir singing
so using that as another way of
preservation so
so that's really what guided me down
this path of interactive media
interesting interesting and so do you
own a 360
camera or do you tend to rent or borrow
cameras when you shoot
so i've done a few i've i've definitely
um just
checked out cam you know rented cameras
just to experiment but there's also some
that are relatively inexpensive like the
insta360 is a great one
i'm always finding ways of um whatever i
don't want to be accessible to other
people so if i want someone in
you know washington dc or in florida to
tell their own stories i always want the
um technology to be accessible so
whether they're on their cell phone
or ipad or an inexpensive vr camera
they're most drawn to because i know you
know i'm not trying to use the
you know half million dollar camera even
though those are nice i want to be able
to um
make sure we're telling as many stories
as possible and getting that in the
hands of
different communities so i found ways to
use um affordable technologies as well
right
so would you describe your this project
and your filmmaking style as sort of
grassroots filmmaking
definitely i definitely start at the
grassroots level with the communities my
goal and my the best case scenario is to
work collaboratively
with the community so they're telling me
what stories they want told and making
sure we're documenting it
from their perspective and from their
point of view so right with my like
guiding force
yeah and and now you know over the last
couple of years this term
co-creation has come into four and at
the mit open documentary lab they
actually have a co-creation studio so
it's interesting that you
um started doing co-creation without
even knowing that it was a thing
you know that was just an instinctive
thing for you to say i want
to not go in and do extractive
filmmaking with my perspective
on projecting what i think the community
is about but to actually ask them and
say
what made your community you know
special and what was it like growing up
here so i think that's really
interesting
absolutely one of the questions we
always try to ask is
what do you want people to know about
your community so like 20 years from now
what do you want to make sure that they
know
50 years from now and that guy's a lot
of our answers and because of that we
get a lot of interest in responses and
stories that you wouldn't hear
otherwise right stories about like
oppression and just focusing on racism
like these are focusing on
families and the homes that they built
and the communities that raised them
and it's just a different perspective
that i haven't seen in a lot of other
media spaces
got it it's so important um i see that
uh
laughlin land productions has a question
about
how can a community can they monetize
um this content once it's you know
uploaded into the mapping blackness
platform
have you even given any thought at all
to
monetization the same way that if you
had made a documentary film
you can license that film to a school or
a school system
um you know here's my lion documentary
or here's my documentary about twinsburg
high to ohio
and you're gonna sign a three-year deal
with me for x amount
that you can show it in your school
system um have you thought about at all
about the business model for mapping
blackness
that's a great um that's a really good
question i haven't thought about how
communities can
monetize it but that's definitely an
important part like these videos are
these
pieces of media they're for the
community they're archiving their
histories
so if there were a way to monetize it
i'm definitely open to exploring that
and in terms of way up further ways to
give back i just haven't
right
yeah we've been talking about um this
project i've been talking with carla and
working with her on this project
since september monetization has not
come up we've been so focused on trying
to just raise money to build the
platform and also we've been focused on
uh narrowing the scope of the project
enough so that it's manageable
and so that it's teachable to you know
um
people of different media making skill
sets
you see what i'm saying so it's like not
assuming that everybody who
is going to engage with mapping
blackness is a professional or
semi-professional filmmaker or
photographer but that
you know it's going to be an 8th grade
teacher it's going to be an 8th grade
student
it's going to be a freshman in college
who's you know in some sort of
american history class who's hopefully
going to engage with this um
so we're approaching i think we have
five minutes left um
i'm trying to think what else so this
whole issue of
engagement have you given any thought to
how could
a local community or a public media
station like a pbs station
or a museum or a high school engage at
mapping blackness before the platform is
actually built have you given any
thought to
you know how you can start engaging with
different community members
right so over the next few months i'm
rolling out um
virtual workshops for various
communities whether it's a station
or a rec center or school or church if
they're interested in learning different
techniques of how to document their
communities
i'm offering workshops that teach you
know what is augmented reality
how do you create your own ar um talking
about 360 video where
tips and tricks to get professional
quality images um i don't want it to be
a
professional platform that is user
generated but making sure everyone has
the
knowledge and skills and technique to
create it and add to it
so over the next few months um if you
guys follow me on linkedin or instagram
or go to my website at um
www.focusarts.com there we go um you can
definitely go to website
updates for the workshops sign up form
get additional information
where you can start learning this
process so because i want to grow this
out and have as many contributors as
possible
awesome awesome um well i think that
wraps it up do you have anything else
that you want to tell the audience or
you know about the project or what are
next steps with the project
um next steps as i'm you know completing
the prototype and getting just the
structure
set up if you if you guys know anyone if
you're interested
in having your community documented or
being part of mapping blackness
definitely reach out to me again go to
my website you can contact me there
email me at
infofocusarts.com and i'd love to have
conversations and just see how we can
move forward
fantastic thank you so much carla for
being our first guest on our brand new
show
i really appreciate it lisa
um and everybody please tune in next
wednesday
same time 12 30 p.m eastern our guests
will be elton glass
whose film who's 180 vr short
pov points of view which is which
focuses on
the dangers of artificial intelligence
especially
in terms of facial recognition being
used for policing in black and brown
communities
so we should have a really interesting
conversation with him next week
please tune in thank you